[Music]
so I'm gonna talk about a few things
today first I'll talk about what eBay
Shop out is I'll explain why we don't
integrate with conversational platforms
in the typical way
I'll explain our approach and then I'll
show how we use Google cloud to make
this architecture possible I'm gonna
focus mostly on kind of overall you know
the breadth of what we built I'm not
going to go super deep on machine
learning or AI I'll cover some of that
but I'd also recommend checking out Tod
morals talk from yesterday it was a
pretty good coverage of kind of the
basics of a bot and the theory behind
that so just give you a sense of the
scale that we operate at these are
eBay's quarterly our second quarter
numbers we have a hundred and
seventy-five million active eBay bars
worldwide
we had 1.1 billion live listings on our
website we did twenty three point six
billion dollars in transaction volume
and sixty percent of our revenue was
international this is powered by
thousands of services making billions of
requests per day my group at eBay
develops entirely new products using the
public cloud we do AI research and
development which includes natural
language processing computer vision
machine translation and search we built
a buying experience for the Chinese
market and what I'm talking about today
is conversational commerce with eBay
shop bot on Google assistant and
facebook Messenger so we use Google
cloud for almost everything don't worry
about trying to digest this slide we
essentially started on compute engine we
played with cloud functions but then we
decided we wanted to kind of formalize
our deployment in execution and we moved
to kubernetes and when you do that it
brings along a lot of other things we
use PPC for our networking cloud load
balancer and firewall rules VPN to
connect into our corporate
infrastructure DNS we use the big data
products and then we also use a
management and security products and
we're a big consumer of the utility
compute products including cloud storage
BigTable and pub sub so I figured it'd
be easiest to show you a video of what
eBay Shop on is so you can see kind of
the breadth of what we're what we built
with this product
[Music]
find me a canon camera with a zoom lens
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right so the vision for eBay shop
bought was an intelligent and trusted
personal shopping assistant that
understands your intent and shops for
and with you this video showed a multi
turn conversational AI that was simple
fast and conversational our AI
demonstrates natural language processing
computer vision and speech recognition
it curates and highlights the best deals
for you
and shows the unique finds we have a
size profile that allows us to remember
your preferences and as you continue to
shop with us will remember what you
entered and personalize your shopping
experience for you and then of course
the end result is an item card where we
take you to an eBay page where you can
purchase the item that you shop for a
major aspect of what we've done here is
ubiquity instead of expecting users to
come to ebay calm or our mobile app we
go to the channels where they already
are if they're in Google assistant or if
they're in facebook Messenger we want
them to be able to shop from that
interface we adjust conversations based
on the capabilities of the channel and
device the user is currently in so if
you're in your kitchen and you have a
Google home you should be able to shop
using your voice from your kitchen we
allow users to interact seamlessly
across devices resuming where they left
off so going back to the example of
using your Google home at some point you
might want to actually see the results
that we provided for you so we can
transfer the conversation from your
Google home to Google assistant on your
phone via visualize
so while ubiquity was our goal we
decided to start with two markets first
one is Google assistant which has over
500 million devices today and facebook
Messenger which has over 1.3 billion
monthly users on Google assistant you
create an action to personalize an
interface as a developer they have over
1 million actions today on facebook
Messenger there are over 300 thousand
BOTS so now I'll jump into the technical
details I'll explain what a
conversational platform normally looks
like and how you would interact with it
and then I talk about why we didn't do
it in the typical way so for any
conversation platform you integrate what
this is kind of the diagram that you
would you would want to build towards on
the Left you have and the users input
device like their phone it could be
Google assistant where they might input
speech it could be it could be a
facebook messenger where you upload an
image and then that's received by the
conversational platform that's converted
into a request that's sent to the custom
web book that you create as a developer
you would of course want to validate
that that request came from the platform
then you had formulate a response and
then send back the response
synchronously or asynchronously to the
platform in the case of facebook
Messenger they have a model that's
completely asynchronous with Google
assistant you have five seconds to
respond to the incoming request and then
finally when the conversational platform
receives the response from your web book
its routes the output to the user so
this is Google suggested variant of this
approach for Google assistant similar to
I had in the last diagram you have the
input device on the left on the right
you have your web book which they use
cloud functions for and all their
samples actions on Google is the name of
their platform that you would develop
against and what's different here is in
the middle they have dialogue flow which
is a natural language processing tool
that they
in this example the user might say ask
eBay what my iPhone is worth this will
be sent from actions on Google to
dialogue flow it will do the natural
language processing and determine that
the intent of this request was a what
it's worth
request and the parameters included a
product parameter with the value of
iPhone X so we actually did start with
dialogue flow for Google home we found
it to be pretty good for rapid
prototyping and it helps you get going
in just a few minutes with a working
integration we built what I just
described in the last page of what it's
worth flow in about five days and we
actually were able to demo it at the
keynote at this conference last year but
as we went further on that integration
we felt like we kind of outgrew dialogue
flow at some point the first issue was
it was challenging to scale out to the
moment for our team their tool is a kind
of a point-and-click website and it
didn't at the time have environment
support or revision control all the kind
of tools that you as developer or nobody
used to having and so we had kind of a
medium-sized team and beyond a few
developers it became kind of challenging
to work with this there's a limited set
of conversational platform integrations
so going back to our original goal being
ubiquitous what you see there on the
right is the the logos from their
website of all the platforms of support
and there are actually a lot more
conversational platforms in the world
than that our original integration was
based on a few key categories where we
imported our catalog into dialogue flow
so they can do the natural language
processing based on our our items in
reality our entire catalog has one point
1 billion listings it was just way too
much to actually import into their
systems and then we had a requirement
for a dynamic multi turn dialogue
dialogue flow is kind of built for more
static
kind of closed retrieval base systems
and then finally we are a big company we
actually do have in-house expertise and
so we didn't feel like we needed kind of
like a more basic tool we wanted to be
able to do something more advanced with
our AI and NLU so not to pick on
dialogue flow but finding the right
off-the-shelf platform in this space is
an ongoing struggle but framework
starting a constant state of flux so
similar dialog flow there's a product
called with the AI that was bought by
Facebook and now if you go to their
website it's almost all geared towards
facebook Messenger it's not really
considered to be a general purpose tool
anymore even though you probably could
use it that way
vendor lock-in and upselling are common
so if you were to look at Skype a few
years ago they had a bot API and you
integrated with with it within a little
bit of time you had to upgrade to the
Microsoft bot framework that went
through a few revisions now it's called
the azure bot service and that's being
used to also upsell people on Microsoft
cognitive services so you might do a
simple free integration and within a
couple years you might actually have to
pay real money to keep it a lot so this
is kind of driven us over time to build
abstractions over these conversational
platforms abstract away the platform
specific details into just a kind of a
closed area so that we're not impacted
by these by this flux from these third
parties and then the other part of the
original diagram I showed that Google
recommended was a use of cloud functions
so when we originally look at this we
ran into a few issues that made a
comment on option for us
one were language limitations our Web
book was written in Scala and it
required no js' there was an issue with
not having wall requested access for
facebook messenger entire security story
is based on getting the wrong requests
computing the hash on it
to a header that they send you without
that support they were parsing the JSON
stripping out whitespace and you could
never get back to the original request
and actually validate that it was secure
there was no SLA so we saw issues with
like uneven response times when we we
were trying to use cloud functions and
then there was no virtual private cloud
support which was an issue for us
because we're using kubernetes with VPC
and in order to access our back-end
services we need to be able to get
through the DPC or otherwise we'd have
to expose our services publicly so this
was my slide I had up until last night
when I read the news that claw punches
now GA and they perished addressed all
these issues so we might actually need
to reevaluate it one they had a Python
support for languages they added
container support so I I don't that
means but I think it means that you can
write an or more can have a normal
docker image and run that anything
tagcloud functions they have raw request
access now they have an SLA they have
EPC support and they even allow you to
run cloud functions inside your gke
environment so definitely worth
revaluing
so let me dig into our approach this is
our architecture at a high level and
I'll briefly go over each the area as we
build it into them later on the left we
have you know a user's input device they
might interact with actions on google or
facebook messenger the request is sent
to our web hook through a Google global
load balancer will immediately try and
identify the user by looking up in our
own internal identity service from there
we'll send the request to our AI
subsystem which will process the request
to generate a response
along the way we'll use reliable
messaging that we built to make sure
that the request is handled and the
response is delivered we record the
request in response in our chat history
and we also do tracking through cloud
pub/sub but the user uploaded any media
like an image will write that media to
cloud storage and we also have a service
for doing notification so that we can
send requests or send messages to the
user proactively so this is our AI
subsystem which is the brains behind a
base shopbot we have a custom NLU for
understanding language we have a
knowledge graph which helps us
understand the relationships between the
things the user is asking about we have
a dialog manager which takes the output
of those two services and combines it
with the content that we provide to
formulate the response for the user and
then this dialog manager will use an AI
memory to remember whether you just said
between conversational turns so going
into our natural language understanding
the area a little more it transforms
natural language text into a formal
machine readable representation so it
handles parsing it'll take a string
break it up into words that identify
nouns and verbs and add other structure
to the original input text it doesn't
tent detection to determine what was the
key thing the user is trying to do and
then it extracts any entities that can
find in the text so basically parameters
to the original intent so the example I
have here is my husband needs some new
black leather dress shoes but I want to
spend less than 20 less than $80 what do
you have so our Enel you will go through
this and it does a bunch of things that
I won't go into completely but the key
thing is it identify the intense so
needs and what you have tells it that
this is a shopping intent the identify
is also entities including gender item
condition color product and price range
and then what you see there on the top
is it did spelling correction so husband
was spelled incorrectly so it corrected
that before try to do the entity
extraction this is something we've had
for a while dialogue flow I think just
announced that they added support for
this yesterday and then on the right we
some like basic sentiment analysis that
we do so that emoji tells us tells us
something about the users state of mind
and we can possibly tailor the response
based on that this runs in kubernetes we
have a variety of machine learn more in
GCS and when the machine starts up it
loads them into persistent SSD backed
volumes we have a knowledge graph that
is a probabilistic inference graph of
eBay user behavioral data it allows us
to infer a shopping funnel so if the
user said shoes we can narrow down the
aspects to just things that are relevant
to shoes it runs with Apache airflow to
pull data out of eBay wiki data our wiki
data Wikipedia and that loads it that's
handled by cloud data proc which is
Google's spark implementation and loads
this into a neo4j graph database at this
point we have over 500 million nodes and
20 billion edges so it requires a large
amount of CPU and memory to run this but
we also use persistent as its defect
volumes as well and we use stateful sets
so that as we deploy it doesn't have to
reload all that data on to the machine
so this is an example of what a what our
knowledge graph looks like just so you
can understand more about it on the Left
let's say the user said shoes we know
usually what their gender is and
especially Facebook messenger where they
have a profile where you can load
information some basic information about
the user so we can skip right to the
next level question which in the case of
a male this graph is saying that there
is a higher chance that he cares about
color as his next question than brand so
we can ask him which color do you prefer
red or blue if it's a female we would go
over to the brand question and ask
deeper fur coach or although our AI
memory maintains conversation maintains
memory across conversational turns it is
our dialogue state and also keeps track
of expected future responses if we are
expecting more input from the user
so going back to the flux that you see
sometimes when you're dealing with with
conversational platforms this is one
area where you might want to build your
own AI memory Google system provides a
dialogue state object that you can use
on their system something like Microsoft
bot framework had this they took it away
so if you're gonna integrate with
something like Cortana through Microsoft
Bob framework you'd have to build this
sort of system anyway so you might as
well use it everywhere it uses a big
table and it's keyed on a conversation
ID which is the ID that the
conversational platform provides to us
through the for each turn of the
conversation and then what we store is
the serialized version of our dialogue
managers in memory context so as we go
through each turn of the conversation we
will load this context out of our a I
memory will update it and then we'll
write it back out the big table
our download manager manages the
dialogue flows it's maintained the
content behind it is maintained by
editors and designers and this is the
voice of eBay shopbot it leverages and
updates our AI memory and it looks at
the NLU output ai memory and the
knowledge graph to generate for the
responses so this can lead to another
question or they can produce results so
I'm going to jump into our web book and
AIC subsystem interaction so our
conversational web book is built in no
js' Express typescript currently lives
in kubernetes as I said but we could
possibly port this to cloud functions in
the future we I built it as a single
service with one router essentially per
conversational platform that we
integrate with we could split that into
separate micro services later on if we
wanted to and the philosophy is for this
to basically just be a translation
mechanism between the third-party
conversational platform and our own
internal request response format that we
call fabric API so this is what it looks
like
it's our internal model of a
conversational event and we call it
fabric because we want to picture our
experience being on an ecosystem of
channels we want the bot to weave
through we originally built this as a
rest JSON based interaction but we
wanted to have a concrete interface to
build against we also wanted to have a
client generation for the various
languages that we integrate with so we
defined this interface using protocol
buffers and I'll go into the each of the
areas there which is basically a subset
of the things that we built for this for
the fabric interface event is a
top-level type and it's
and caps lights a lot of things you
would see across conversational
platforms so sender recipient
conversation for maintaining context
across conversational turns we encode
capabilities that might come from the
request and then we break down the event
type into either a message a post back
which is essentially a button click and
then we could differentiate between new
users and returning users who are
starting a new conversation with us our
message type allows us to handle both
speech and text it allows the user to
upload media including images audio
video and files it has a scheduled
attribute that allows us to basically
delay messages so we can kind of provide
pauses in the user interaction we also
have a typing indicator in there as well
that makes it look like the bot is
thinking we have a card type that's kind
of generic card that we can use to fill
and with any any items but usually we
use it for an eBay product so we put in
there the title a price a description
and image and buttons that you used
interact with it
going back to the message we have a
carousel which is a horizontally
scrolling set of cards and we have a
list template which is a vertical
version of the same thing
so one of the key things here is
modeling channel and device capabilities
so we want to be able to adapt the
responses to the channel and device so
we have static config based on the
channel so for example what you see here
on the right is Google assistant showing
a vertical list on Google assistant this
can handle up to 30 items on facebook
Messenger there vertical list can handle
4 items so when we're integrating with
this we want to be able to factor in the
different capabilities of the different
channels we also have dynamic config
based on the incoming request and this
is especially important on Google
assistant where you can have a Google
home that's purely voiced based where
you have a cool assistant on your phone
that has a screen interaction so we need
to be able to factor in the two types of
you know voice and screen bass
interactions Nvidia shield is one
product that has cool assistant running
on it but they didn't add a web browser
yet so we can't have the user link to
ebay.com for example so we need to
factor in all these different
capabilities when we format our response
and when we do that though we want to
avoid having channel specific logic
because we're trying to create they
bought that has kind of a consistent
voice across these different channels we
want to be able to use that content
across those channels without having
logic that says if messenger or if
actions on Google we want to be able to
say like basically in terms of
capabilities this is what you can show
that would optimize experience for this
device the user has so just to kind of
drive that home this is an example of
what that looks like on actions on
Google and patient messenger these are
the basic request payloads that you
would get in both cases the user said
hello world and we could translate that
into a single fabric request and it
looks almost identical between the two
we encapsulate the or we include the
user ID which our internal user ID we
record the channel ID and we take the
conversation ID that the conversational
platform gave us and add that here as
well we have capabilities and then
finally in our message list we include
the original hello world text message
the response is pretty much the same
thing in this case Rai Rai responded
with you said hello world and we have
channel specific code in our web book
that can translate the fabric response
into either actions on Google or
Facebook Messenger and what you see
there is what that looks like in each of
those platforms
so at this point supporting additional
channels has become more of a business
decision than an engineering one we have
a common back-end shared by all channels
and we just have to create a new Express
router in our app and set the end point
for that in our conversational platform
the biggest challenge is then mapping
the external request response format
into our fabric API and accounting for
any unique capabilities that that
channel might have we've already
validated this approach so beyond Google
assistant and messenger we've done this
integration with Cortana and Skype SMS
slack and we've got something basic
working that we know we could easily
scale out if we chose to take our
business in that direction so I'll go
into some of the supporting systems now
these are not major systems or any major
components of what we built but I think
is interesting to look at them because
they were built
I have Emily leveraging GCP and it's the
sort of thing it would take a lot more
work to build off tcp like on a
traditional platform so we built our
chat history and BigTable and we want to
archive incoming and outgoing messages
so some use cases include internal
dashboards to visualize conversations
analytics retraining our AI models and
handover to a human operator we
basically just rying to record a JSON
sterilized version of the message we
include some metadata we have a version
attribute that allows us to know how to
parse that message we include the
channel and then we include ascent from
user value basically know it was a
request or response that we're recording
here the key thing here if you spend any
time at BigTable is on that key design
and this kind of aligns with big tables
best practice for how how to build the
key but we want to be able to retrieve
based on a user ID so that's the first
component of our key then we also want
to be able to make sure that the
messages are in order according to the
time of the user
acted with with our BOTS so we use a
timestamp we wanted to be able to get
those most recent first
so we reverse the timestamp and then we
use a random number in case there are
multiple concurrent writers we don't
want them to overwrite each other and
then if we're recording multiple
messages at once we have a batch ID
that's sequential for that batch so it
all kind of comes together and gives us
one kind of easy interact with
lightweight chat history system we
actually built a reliable busting system
and big table so the thing here is we
want to make sure that every input and
the user gets a response if something
goes wrong in our back-end and we drop a
request it looks really bad essentially
looks like the bot is just not
functioning very well it's low quality
and it also aligns with Facebook
messengers interaction with Web books
which is they'll send your requests and
they expect you to return a 200 response
and if you don't they'll retry to get in
20 seconds you return too many failures
they'll disable your bought altogether
so no matter what happens we want to be
able return a 200 so the system we built
takes a request from messenger and we
immediately run into BigTable each user
has their own queue which is represented
by a row and BigTable and the message is
written to a column with a sequential
monotonically increasing ID we'll try
and set the message if we can right away
but if something goes wrong a worker
will pick up a little scan the table it
will pick up the row that still has all
standing messages it will atomically try
at least the row and then it'll send the
messages one by one after all the
columns are deleted it will release the
lease and then all the messages should
be sent at that point so this ensures
ordered at least once delivery we do
have some edge cases where could
possibly result in duplicates but we
figured that was better than having no
responses at all and this is something
we built over a year ago we haven't had
any problems that really you have big
table issues that are kind of
within their SLA so we have blips here
and there it hasn't really impacted
users and every time we've had one of
these blips is recovered on its own so
conversational platforms will deliver
media in different ways on the right you
see an image being uploaded from
facebook Messenger and when that's sent
to our service it's in the form of a
short-lived URL and other platforms
might deliver these this media in
different ways so we want to extract
those details from our back-end services
so at the edge in our web book we may
record any uploaded media into GCS and
then the GCS key is what we pass around
to our back-end and once again is
something just works for us it was very
fast for us to implement this and we
haven't had to think about it since we
launched we built our notification
system with cloud datastore so this is
what proactively sends messages to users
we handled package tracking events deals
editors picks and marketing campaigns
use descriptions are stored in datastore
so the user will subscribe or
unsubscribe to a notification through
their conversational interface it will
be sent to our notification service
which records that in the notifications
dB we have quartz cron jobs that run
periodically to check to see if any
notifications need to be sent it will
receive events from eBay to know when
package tracking updates happened and we
also call in to our deals API to look up
any new deals for the users when this
notification system runs is invoked by
courts we get a transaction to
essentially lock the processing of the
notifications to a single worker and
this is one area we actually might want
to revisit our decision to use datastore
we used it at the time because it was
new
and we wanted to see how performed and
we've run into great limiting issues
with a time and again so probably what
we do instead is use a traditional
relational database or cloud SQL or
something else like that we built our
analytic system on DCP and what you see
here is actually a pretty standard our
service will track requests and
responses in cloud pub/sub we have cloud
dataflow that does the stream process of
any events and it persists the results
into cloud storage what you see on the
right is a data studio dashboard it's
not ours is just a sample just to give
an idea what it looks like and when the
user loads the dashboard it goes through
bigquery to load the external data from
cloud storage summarise it and then
present it to the user so tying this all
together i'm going to show a video of
google assistant in action and I didn't
go into localization or multi region
support but just a heads up this is done
from the from the viewpoint of an
Australian user to find me a Kate Spade
bag okay
got it looking for a color that black
brown or something else what great - you
want a style that shoulder bag messenger
in crossbody or something else shoulder
bone I looked through seven options on
eBay and the best tool on this item is
$95 I have more info on this still for
you is it okay if I send that to your
home yes
[Music]
okay so just to summarize what you saw
there was a few things that I talked
about in action we showed our AI so when
the user says asking me for a Kate Spade
bag our Lu will try and parse that input
it will go to our knowledge graph and
try and find additional attributes about
Kate Spade bags so including color and
style it uses our dialogue manager to
process the output of the MOU in the
knowledge graph and then takes the
content that it has internally and
formats responses it uses the AI memory
so that remembers across these three
turns what the user inputted and then
finally it returns results we use the
fabric API so that we can translate from
the conversational platform Google
assistance requests a response format
into the format that our AI understands
internally and then we factor N channel
device capabilities so the initial
interaction was through Google home and
it's a completely voice based interface
and we had to tailor the response with
the expectation that the user didn't
have a screen to look at so at the very
end when we had results to present to
them we asked them do they want to
transfer this conversation over to their
phone on Google assistant and that's
what happened there we loaded the final
results out of our ai memory and when
the user came in from their phone we
presented them with an ID card showing
them the results so in summary eBay
shopbot is an intelligent and trusted
personal shopping assistant available
today for Google assistant and facebook
Messenger we ran into issues that cause
us to not use dialogue flow or the
traditional way you would integrate with
conversational platform we built our own
AI stack and we have a request response
format we translate external formats
into so we can handle them in a platform
neutral way we built this all on Google
cloud and to help make this entire
architecture possible
all right thank you
[Music]